Eeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeee,they don't get
along well with us long-distance type
It's not because
it was created with another purpose in mind,
but
Mr. Kuroi
seems to have created a little bit of diversity based on
his own settings pandan.
Then just choose the path
you chose and go ahead ana Stay strong and re-run until the arrow ends
Do you think cancel
me
[music] It's the
best
tar?